[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier zum letzten
video aus new york der tag heute wird
bestehen aus nicht stück rückflug nach
düsseldorf und das wird auch nach berlin
ziehen in berlin mit max ganz vielen
anderen leuten wo ich auch mal film
werde und flug von berlin zurück nach
ich weiß gar nicht wer von befindet sich
damit an die gestern waren in den platz
wieder den einen bagel haben mit campino
monate geholt und nach dem kanadischen
markt das die eigentlich immer zu wenig
mit schönen arbeiten und danach
fand ich einfach unseren besten 20
stunden über den ganzen tag etwas ihrer
freunde meinen fans und dem grafen fährt
in drei oder vier minuten nicht um einen
anderen kurs
ich bin jetzt am arsch
ja
[Musik]
diese schlucker natürlich wieder ticket
zug vergessen dann erst mal aber mit den
typen zweiten liga geht in 30 minuten
gemeint habe ich von flake hissen blabla
dass ich meinen koffer doch noch
irgendwie abgeben kann
ich hoffe mal das netz 100 euro mit flug
helfen hast ich musste dieses
gepäckstück jetzt mit als handgepäck
mitnehmen weil irgendjemand nur das kann
ich nur das kleine pohlig 20 minuten
wurde und er irgendwie kriegt business
ticket hatte jetzt muss ich daraus
sachen die shampoo de und so
wegschmeißen
ich habe einen zuschauer getroffen ich
mag ich bin dafür denn ich komme aus
dortmund und was ist jetzt in new york
gemacht ich bin ja in worcester haben
ein jahr kommen so ein austausch gemacht
ja das ist der erste der mich in new
york mit sich jetzt hier im flughafen
kennt das ist richtig aber unser flug
hat gegen die verspätung oder so also
eigentlich nicht schon längst drauf aber
mal schauen ob das noch passiert
[Musik]
ich hätte mich gerade auf der hand und
zurück
ich will mich da
nicht immer
wahrscheinlich nicht
mainz
nein
[Musik]
und nicht
[Applaus]
ich bin gelandet ich hab wieder boden
unter den füßen ich laufe gerade durch
den flughafen düsseldorf muss jetzt
meinen anschlussflug nach werden diese
heute bewegende kaputt ich muss jetzt
mal einen anschlussflug nach berlin
erwischen hoffe dass ich das hinkriege
meinen koffer sich zumindest schon mal
ich bin so caro von dem flug das war
echt der schlimmste flug den ich hier
hatte also großes licht und ist damit
vorbei sagt um einen gott und ich weiß
nicht was ich dazu sagen soll also mein
gott
ich
bin einfach nur froh wieder boden unter
den füßen zu haben keine taktik für alle
anzubieten wenn das länger dauert weil
die sicherheitskontrolle einfach
vorgehen und sagen euer verortet sofort
kommt der ford hat jetzt auch wieder
geklappt
risiko
wir sind gerade bei die move in berlin
nicht am mega den jetlag und da sehen
wir im ja hallo hier haben wir werden
jetzt dorthin gibt ein paar fotos
aufnehmen wo wir bilder machen werden
für ein kommendes projekt möchte ich das
jetzt gar nicht mehr hochladen
[Musik]
je kleiner freund ich habe beide male
mein handy verloren
im taxi und da bringen wir das jetzt
gleich zurück irgendwann fünf minuten
oder sorgt deswegen nicht mal mein her
das ist richtig schön dass es noch so
ehrliche menschen gibt die werden sie
ein handy im taxi finden das wirklich
auch zurückgeben
auch marks was für sie wieder eine
schöne jetzt ok wird man nicht mehr müde
und der kann man schon ins bett gehen zu
sein
man kommt wieder zu sich wieder
ok
normal sind danke
doch man sieht sich
der taxifahrer
[Musik]
des halb zehn abends und ich bin gerade
so richtig zu hause angekommen es gab
noch ein paar komplikationen mit käufer
abholen und dann wurde ich noch mehr
kann und haben mit paletten gelagert und
noch ein paar freunde getroffen und dann
beim joggen und trainieren
und jetzt bin ich hier gerade am sachen
auspacken genau diese sequenz bildet
jetzt den abschluss der kompletten new
york reihe beziehungsweise dieser woche
dieser wie lok woche sage ich mal da
haben von montag bis jetzt am freitag
die ganze zeit wie loks kam ich kann zu
diesem moment zwar noch nicht sagen
wieviel arbeit mich das ganze
tatsächlich nachher im schnitt gekostet
hat allerdings habe ich derzeit schon so
viele ideen im kopf wie ich das ganze
zusammen schneiden möchte das ist
wahrscheinlich richtig viel arbeit für
mich noch wir wenn euch die blogs bisher
gefallen und auch dieser block würde ich
mich definitiv bei der bewertung freuen
weil wir das einfach zeigt euch gefallen
oder nicht sonst möchte hier gar nicht
lange drum rumreden mehr hat diese woche
mega viel spaß mache ich habe mega viel
erlebt mega viel erfahrungen und
weisheit noch mein leben mitgenommen
ja
[Applaus]
a